YP you know Millennials and Gen Z's re
are reconnecting with the church or
connecting for the first time to faith I
think large in part due to the failure
you know perhaps of of secularism it
doesn't work and there's questions I
think that that it's attempted to answer
that it hasn't answered and that's why
you'll even see guys like Sam Harris who
have become spiritual not in any sort of
Orthodox sense but an awareness that
maybe there is something out there that
aren't we connect to and soul and spirit
etc I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin
report quick reminder everybody to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
click that pesky notification bell and
joining me today is an author and a
teaching pastor Nathan finocchio welcome
to the Rubin report hey it's good to be
here I'm glad to have you sir because as
you probably know I do some talking to
people of faith people better skeptics
people that are somewhere in between and
I always find these to be sort of the
most interesting conversations that I
have so before we do anything about what
you're doing now tell me a little bit
about your journey to fate yes so I'm
the son of a preacher man my dad has
been in the ministry as long as I could
remember and
sort of just fallen into it to be quite
honest I tried to not necessarily run
the other way but do something else and
sort of just caught up to me you know
it's like you know so just kind of this
is what I do now because it's just kind
of right what I know but I do I do
you don't have a I've always had a kind
of strong faith in God I just never saw
myself as the ministerial type because
you know like people of faith
I guess spiritual leaders they kind of
happen to type in my name there there my
opinion there they're kind of square and
they stay home on Friday nights and play
Scrabble with Grandma and there's just
not what I wanted to do with my life you
know hey don't knock Scrabble man
everybody loves Scrabble look I take
that back okay Scrabble is great and
grandma's wonderful well to your point
though you kinda it's like well wait a
minute look at this guy he doesn't
really look like a pastor and then on
the other hand you look like sort of a
modern Jesus so you're you're sort of
doing a little everything over there um
it's you know it's a work in progress
did you on the way you said you did a
little something before going into this
even though you came from a family of
faith uh what was the faith part always
there or did you mean that you deviated
from that too or did you just mean that
sort of career-wise or something else I
just think that's sort of career wise
yeah I was doing music for about eight
years and so oh yeah it's kind of doing
that and things just didn't work out the
way I kind of wanted them to work out I
sort of went back to went back to the
family farm so to speak and so I'm just
kind of been doing ministry now for the
last gosh I don't know last six years
so if somebody said you sort of lay out
what your belief system is what would
that be kind of broadly speaking yeah so
I'm I'm a confessional Christian that's
what I'd say I'm in the kind of the
brand of Christianity that I'm or the
stream that I flow in it's more of a
Pentecostal Christianity you know so
we're the ones that I mean I've never
handled a snake before but that's what
kind of what meta Gospels are known for
you know tambourine destroying
Pentecostals we're the ones that when
you go to our churches on the weekend
it's kind of like a rock concert so
we've got lasers and you know we could
kind of attract a younger crowd but our
idea basically is that we have a a
historic Orthodox confessional Christian
doctrine so we believed that the stuff
that the church has always believed and
we confess and we profess that but the
we wrap it up in sort of a modern in a
modern vibe yeah do you get a lot of
pushback on that sort of I've seen this
in a few different versions where
there's you know the sort of belief that
you just have to have the belief and the
the orthodoxy and and the conservative
look at religion and then you bring in
music you bring in lasers you bring in
bands and all sorts other stuff and
people a certain set of people will
think that that will kind of erode the
original message yeah
yeah I think that that's utter and total
ridiculousness basically I mean look at
Vatican 3 and kind of what the Catholic
Church is done like is having services
in English somehow diminish the Catholic
churches you know their their message no
it doesn't so that's essentially what
we're doing where whereas they're just
there for them progress is translating
the math from Latin to English for us
we're doing exactly that we're
translating the message but like you
know the currency I think of our
generation is music and the arts and so
that's kind of how we we communicated
that language right so sort of speaking
of music in the arts what kind of put
you on my radar is that Justin Bieber is
a member of the church I don't want you
to get into any any specifics about
anyone that goes to the church but but
what do you sense is happening with
people of his age related to belief
there does seem to be something going on
you know Kanye's running these services
now and you know as you just said it's
sort of related to music and culture and
something else it's not what we think of
when we just think of like the
traditional religious perspective yeah
hundred percent I think people I know
you mentioned Justin and Kanye as far as
I know they had a church upbringing so
there's a lot a lot of people come up in
the church I know Justin for a fact it I
went to I I spoke at his home Church in
Canada I'm actually Canadian I I grew up
45 minutes from where he grew up so I
know like I mean Elvis for crying out
loud you know came up in the churches
it's not uncommon in the American story
the people in the arts come up in church
and then they kind of leave the small
town and they go do big musical things
so but in terms of a returner I mean we
saw it even in Elvis's career you know
the only album they'd ever won a Grammy
for was for his gospel record so there's
something I think intrinsic to Americana
and the church and music so it's pretty
common common theme YP you know
Millennials and Gen Z's are weak or
reconnecting with the church or
connecting for the first time to faith I
think large in part due to the failure
you know perhaps of secularism it
doesn't work and there's questions I
think that that it's attempted to answer
that it hasn't answered and that's why
you'll even see guys like Sam Harris who
have become spiritual not in any sort of
Orthodox sense but an awareness that
maybe there is something out there that
aren't we connect to and soul and spirit
etc so I think we have something to
offer people that is that is reasonable
and that is also experiential
so one of the things that I've been
talking about on the show a lot lately
is that I think a lot of the problems
we're having is that we seem to be
reaching the end of secularism which i
think is sort of what you're alluding to
that when you get to the end of pure
secularism with nothing else outside of
itself that everything's on the table
again and we don't know if men are men
and women are women and we're debating
destroying you know our past in the name
of some utopian future and the rest of
it do you see that as just like the
natural kind of outgrowth of what of
what a purely secular society is yeah I
think gosh you know without getting into
a huge history lesson well what I would
call I think there's two types of
there's two types of people in our
churches right now okay there's we what
we would make might call leftists and a
secular might be a secularist might be a
better term but and then we have you
know for lack of a better term a
conservative which I can't stand the
term but but just using generalizations
and what I think has happened as a
society is that we have an
epistemological crisis that's kind of
what happened with what has happened
because secularism is the idea
essentially that material is the only
thing that you can touch and we get
always you don't live together in our
material society and let's forget about
things that are not our non material
like spirituality because those things
will just divide us and it's kind of be
kind of works out at first but then it
begins to hammer down everybody into
just material and people aren't just
material and the world isn't just
material there's a lot more to it if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell